- Don't you dare!
(suspenseful music)
- [Pickle] I don't know
how to do this part.
- [Producer] 30 seconds.
- [Anita] 29, 28...
- 20 seconds left!
(giggling)
- Wrap it up ladies!
- [All] Three,
two...
(upbeat music)
- Oh, I
love
drag.
- I follow a lot
of drag queens on Instagram,
and I'm really excited about the look
so I wanna see how it looks on me.
- I'm not very familiar.
I saw the movie To Wong Foo when I was 12.
- Every time I'm in drag, it's
just so empowering and fun.
You get to take on this different persona.
I'm really excited to get back in touch
with that side of myself.
- I think I'm gonna be the prettiest.
I'm in it to win it.
- I'm ready to meet my queen!
- They are fucking it up, I know they are.
Just pluck that chest hair.
- Girl, you look great.
- [Pickle] You're gonna do so well.
- I am bargain bin beauty, Roz Drezfalez.
You get what you pay for.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you been doing drag?
- This is my first time.
- Hi, I'm Pickle, the
youngest MILF in town.
Doing drag is really about
accentuating the qualities
about myself that are delightful.
I love putting that on other people.
I think it's really empowering.
- Hi, Anita Procedure,
and I am accepting
donations for my procedure,
so you can find me on Venmo.
My mom and my sister were my
biggest influences as a kid.
So they bought her a Cinderella dress,
they knew they had to buy me one.
- How comfortable am I
doing people's makeup?
Not very.
That means I have to wash my brushes,
on the off chance that he catches
rickets or diphtheria.
Not my problem.
- Hopefully he ends up liking what I do,
but if not, oh well!
It's going on the internet forever.
- Drag to me is really important--
- It's time to the boys!
- God damn it!
- The boys!
- Bring in the men!
- Oh, boys!
Yeah, I like boys!
- Hi, my name's Anita Procedure.
- I'm Jared,
and I think we're gonna win.
- Oh yeah, we're going to
be the prettiest for sure.
- Hi!
- I get to do your makeup?
- Yeah.
- Do you know about drag?
- A little bit.
- Hi.
How are you?
- I'm Pickle.
- Ben.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you,
I'll definitely remember that.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna make you look
like a beautiful cucumber.
You'll never be me.
- What look are we thinking?
- I like the weirder stuff.
- Ooh, weird.
- Little crazier.
Do I trust her?
Yeah, of course I trust her.
She's my guiding queen.
- Check your wallet.
- Come on Buzzfeed, let's get into drag!
(upbeat rock music)
- All right ladies,
let's turn these hes into shes.
- [Anita] Let's do it, come on!
(upbeat music)
- I don't know how to do this part.
(chuckles) I barely do it on myself.
(upbeat music)
Can you help me with this lash?
- Well, I sorta fucked up the lip,
so just trying to fix that,
but then I gotta put her wig on,
and she's gonna be show ready!
- [Producer] 30 seconds.
- 30!
- Shit!
- [Anita] 29,
28--
- Shit.
I wish I could go back in time
and tell the earlier Pickle
to hurry the fuck up.
- Wrap it up ladies!
- [All] Three, two, one...
- I would like to present to you all,
Shegada Procedure!
- Oh,
my
God.
- Oh my God,
what do you think?
- I fucking love it.
- Yes!
I'll take that.
Oh my God, you look
like you're ready to go
to an 80s Glamour Shot shoot.
(upbeat music)
- Okay, you ready to see what I did?
- [Ian] Let's see what happens.
(Roz cheering)
(Ian laughing)
- [Roz] Ladies and gentleman,
Penny Pincher.
So basically, she was on
her way to high school,
and the Zodiac Killer snatched her up.
- I like it.
I mean I look like I'm
in a Swedish metal band,
suits my personality.
- All right,
welcome to stage,
Cucumber!
(Cucumber laughing)
- [Cucumber] Oh my goodness, look at her.
Wow, this is great.
- How does it feel?
- I feel like a woman.
- I know.
- I feel like
a real life woman.
- You look like a woman.
- [Cucumber] I'm like
falling in love with it.
- You recognize yourself?
- I don't.
- Do you feel like
you look different.
- (chuckles) I don't know
who that is.
It's so weird,
it's like I'm controlling--
- Some other person?
- Someone else, yeah.
- You're beautiful.
Tell yourself.
- I'm beautiful.
- Good.
- Thanks Pickle.
- You're fuckin' welcome.
(upbeat music)
- I think we did great.
We did, what do you boys think?
I mean, you ladies.
- Gherkin could literally live as a woman.
- What about mine?
- [Anita] She's sort of
like Hot Topic realness.
- I feel like everyone's beautiful,
but we're the winners clearly.
- Ah!
I like her.
She's so sassy.
- Oh, shady.
- We came here as boys
and we're leaving as queens.
- Yes!
(Anita chuckling)
- Come on hennies.
- Let's go girls.
- Where we going?
- Let's hit the club.
No, actually you guys have
to work though, right?
- Yeah.
- Yep.
(sign squeaks)